in der kuh
ok also hier von der gamescom heute
klickst du mit jan müller-michaelis
cookie der hat unter anderem edna bricht
aus entwickelt und viel mehr und der
sagt es gibt und umbruch in der gaming
große branche wenn leute wie ich ergänze
entwickeln können da kommt noch viel
interessantes auf den markt warum das so
ist erzählt er jetzt gibt auch ganz
schön kompakt
ja hallo grüß dich wie ist die lage ja
gut ist die lage gut ist die lage wenn
es macht spaß besonders schöne sachen
zeigen kann und wir stehen ja kurz vor
vollendung unseres aktuellen projekts
chaos auf deponie avaz der zweite teil
der deponie trilogie ist und wir sind
schon so weit mit dem projekt das wir
eben einfach was schönes zu präsentieren
habe das macht natürlich spaß dass dann
der presse vorzustellen und die erste
reaktion von dem publikum zu sehen
sozusagen das macht spaß wie lange hat
das bis zu diesem moment gedauert
das lässt sich gerade im fall von
deponie sehr sehr schwer sagen denn er
hat überlebt hatte eine sehr großzügig
bemessen produktionsphase da habe ich
fast ein jahr nur an dem konzept
gearbeitet möglicherweise sogar drüber
ich weiß es gar nicht mehr so genau und
hat bald schon alle drei teile vor
geplant dann also ursprünglich war sogar
einmal ein großer teil geplant dass wir
halt gemerkt haben wir so viel content
und wir wollen uns eigentlich auch um
die kleinen situation kümmern
das sind eigentlich drei spiele und dann
haben wir es halt in der mitte an den
entscheidenden
wendepunkt sozusagen an den
entscheidenden höhepunkten des spiels
aufgetrennt und noch ein bisschen konnte
dazu gemacht und ja das heißt 4 2 musste
ich auch noch mal eine kleine re design
phase machen wo ich halt den anschluss
an kapitel eins noch mal neu schreiben
musste und dann haben wir angefangen das
spiel zusammen zu setzen hatten aber
auch schon vorgearbeitet also gerade was
die hintergründe anbetrifft wir machen
ja 2d point click adventures und das
heißt alle hintergründe sind per hand
gemalt wir hatten viele von den
animationen schon vorbereitet natürlich
rufen sie noch genauso aus wie ein teil
1 und konnten dann von dieser basis aus
loslegen und ja da hat es gar nicht so
lange gedauert denn der einzig ja gerade
jetzt ist und januar herausgekommen das
heißt wir arbeiten da mit highspeed und
kaum ein halbes jahr später also acht
monate später sind wir eigentlich schon
fertig mit dem spiel also auf highspeed
ich habe auch und so gut super team ok
du sagst gerade 2 d
wenn man hier über die messe geht dann
ist das 3d und umso mehr effekte umso
besser warum kann man heute noch spiele
im stile von monkey island erfolgreich
machen
obwohl der rest der branche in eine ganz
andere richtung geht ja das ist ja schon
fast gar nicht mehr wahr also als wir
anfingen mit der liegt also bei
firmengründung vor etwas über fünf
jahren fünfeinhalb jahren da war das
tatsächlich so dass wir die absolute
exoten waren und das halt alle uns
angeguckt haben gefragt sich gefragt
haben was machen die denn da machen wir
wieder zwei d also ich persönlich finde
dass das diese optik halt für die
spieler einfach wie gemacht ist ja ein
erzählerisches spiel und man möchte halt
das dass die geschichte die man da
erlebt die ein vordergrund des
spielerlebnisses steht dass diese
geschichte halt irgendwie konkurrieren
kann mit den medien im fernsehen
sozusagen mit dem was man da
davon da kennt und das 3d was seit
vielen computerspielen haben es halt nur
dann eigentlich mit einem sehr extrem
hohen budget kann es hat eigentlich
immer noch nicht mit dem was wir aus dem
kino kennen so pixar oder realistische
3d filme gibt es jetzt sehr wenige tim
und struppi oder konkurrieren also noch
nicht mal das bald natürlich immer von
der rechner performance abhängt und 2d
ist aber nur das was es ist also wenn
eine krankheit fertig gezeichnet ist
dann wieder halt genauso aus wie auf der
kinoleinwand und das ist vielleicht das
was mich halt an dem stil reiz dass du
da auf dem computer genau das siehst was
du halt auch auf dem fernseher
bildschirm oder auf der kinoleinwand
sehen würdest und du kriegst rum und es
bewegt sich halt auch genau so ist es
ist das vielleicht auch so ein trend
wenn ich jetzt hier spiele vorstellungen
sehr zum einen ist es natürlich so es
gibt die x-te version von dem ein oder
anderen ego shooter aber es gibt auch
sehr viele spiele wo es inzwischen immer
mehr um fantasie um storytelling und so
weitergeht hat sich da im grunde oder
ist die spielebranche erwachsen geworden
ja ob das jetzt in richtung in erwachsen
ist oder nicht die wirklich tollen für
erwachsene sondern im sinne von das hat
sich professionalisieren künstler am
werk auf jeden fall die die
die branche sei insgesamt noch sehr jung
wenn man mal bedenkt dass die ersten
kommerziellen computerspiele in den 70er
jahren hat auf den markt kamen und lange
zeit konnten computerspiele halt auch
nur von irgendwelchen total freakigen
lörz gemacht werden
aber heutzutage nicht mehr so um sich
etwas zu ärgern
heute da gibt es auch noch andere leute
also die nicht so viel natürlich schon
auch zu den apps aber es gibt halt sehr
viel wind jetzt gerade aktuell außer
independent branche also independence
spiele die halt von sehr kleinen gruppen
meistens sogar in der freizeit
entwickelt werden und auf eigene kosten
haben plötzlich ein marktplatz werden
über das internet verteilt es gibt aber
auch die entsprechenden download
plattformen auf konsolen und aus dieser
richtung kommen halt sehr viele neue
ideen und gerade dieses spiel habe also
auch immer gezeigt dass wenn die idee
gut ist dass die optik des spiels halt
nicht high end 3d grafik
hyperrealistisch sein muss wenn du jetzt
eine gute art style ist kann das
durchaus sogar charmanter sein als ja
als halt immer zu sagen
ein spiel muss sonderlich realistisch
sein das heißt wir beobachten sie auf
youtube da gibt es immer mehr jüngere
leute die gar nicht den weg durch
irgendwie lange studien und praktika
oder ende gegangen sind sondern die
fangen an was zu machen und haben erfolg
ist das hat das sich auch oder ich sage
ich nichts demokratisierung der medien
ist das auch im gaming bereich so dass
einfach leute die möglichkeit haben an
die öffentlichkeit zu kommen ohne großen
publisher ja genau das ist im prinzip
genau der effekt von dem ich gerade
gesprochen habe es gibt plötzlich
independent spielergruppen die hat ein
sehr großes publikum
erreichen können spieler wie braid oder
fest oder limo zum beispiel sind halt
alle von sehr kleinen independent
entwicklern entwickelt worden und haben
eine riesige öffentlichkeit gefunden und
im prinzip war es auch bei uns nicht
anders denn edna bricht aus ist halt
noch für unser firmengründung also unser
erstes spiel podiums namen noch während
meines studiums entstanden und auch bei
mir zu hause am computer also im prinzip
sind wir genauso außen kommen wir genau
aus diesem bereich aus dem independent
bereich hast du denn damit gerechnet
dass das passieren wird weil das spiel
ist ja schon gegen eine ganz andere
richtung als das was es vorher gab würde
ich jetzt mal so behaupten ja also ich
hab natürlich während der erstellung des
spiels unglaubliche mühe gegeben
irgendwas zu machen was ich selber auch
spielen würde also aber das ist
tatsächlich dafür auch den markt gibt
also ich bin natürlich auch davon
ausgegangen dass es andere leute gibt
die mich die dieses klassische point and
click adventure sehr vermissen die erst
gar nicht eingesehen haben dass es
plötzlich mitte der neunzigerjahre
solche spiele gar nicht mehr richtig gab
aber ich würde schon ein bisschen raus
mit dem erfolg hättest du nicht gerecht
auch mit dem erfolg gehabt tatsächlich
nicht gerecht und nein als dann die
ersten reviews kam und die presse sich
hat plötzlich überschlagen hat da haben
wir halt alle mit großen augen davor
gesessen
besonders weil wir vorher mit dem spiel
ja fast jeden publisher in deutschland
abgelaufen sind und immer ganz
schüchtern gefragt haben und wir hätten
hier auch noch ein spiel das ist aus den
opern im bereich das ist halt dort
entstanden
guckt euch mal an und alle so haben uns
halt eher belächelt dafür
und ja mal garnicht tiefer reingeguckt
weil es eben nicht so aussieht wie viel
spielen sondern halt eben sehr von
meinem spiel
abhängig ist so zusammen ihr habt damit
mit euren spielen inzwischen ohne ende
preise abgeräumt
auch das ist tatsächlich richtig freut
mich natürlich sehr dass unsere spieler
hat darüber dass der darüber hat auch
undercover und eben diese der
öffentlichkeit bekommen das schon ein
kleines wunder für uns also dass da ist
man schon teilweise sehr sprachlos
gerade letztes jahr hat habe ich neue
augen der nachfolger von edna bricht aus
beim entwicklerpreis den dänen den preis
für das beste art design bekommen ich
musste da auf die bühne gehen und habe
im publikum halt die leute für die die
ganzen ortes von crytek sitzen sehen und
die guckt mich alle ganz böse an
ich bin da ganz klein geworden ich
glaube von die brüder muss man auch
angst haben ein kleiner scherz
ich werde gleich mal fragen wohin geht
die reise
was würdest du sagen in der
gaming-branche wenn solche entwickler
wie du eine chance haben
was werden wir in zehn jahren sehen ja
ich hoffe wir sehen viel mehr vielfalt
hat es jetzt momentan man sieht ja schon
den umbruch also der trend geht auf
jeden fall dahin
ich denke dass wir oder ich hoffe dass
wir halt viel mehr von diesem input aus
dem independent bereich einsetzen können
aber eben denke ich auch dass das dass
das thema interaktive dramaturgie also
dass das erzählen mit dem computerspiel
ja auf jeden fall auflagen
hochkonjunktur fahrt ist also in
richtung
in der richtung wird noch sehr viel
passieren da sind halt noch lange nicht
alle geschichten erzählt und noch gar
nicht alle mechanismen erkundet worden
wie man interaktive geschichte erleben
kann weil wir haben klassischerweise ist
bei computerspielen so dass ins spiel
und es hat außerdem noch eine geschichte
aber diese vernetzung zwischen
geschichte und dem gameplay das wird
halt gerade erst erforscht was da alles
machbar ist ist ja eigentlich schon seit
den 80er jahren da gab es die ersten
projekte
es wird ja eigentlich schon ewig daran
geforscht aber es ist kann man kann sich
von einem 1000 anderen irgendwie lösen
oder alles herausfinden oder ja genauso
es einfach ein pferd großer bereich ist
es fast so als hätte man neuen kontinent
entdeckt und jetzt meter für meter
steckt man halt sein land ab merkt oh
dahinter geht es noch weiter und hinter
dem berg geht noch weiter und noch
weiter und noch weiter und gerade jetzt
spiele wie heavy rain oder jetzt ganz
aktuell walking dead von tell tale
eröffnet ganz neue erzählen mechanismen
die wir halt während des spiels erleben
und gar nicht in zwischensequenzen
zwischen dem spielerlebnis
ja und wir versuchen natürlich auch
unsere schiffe dazu zu geben und
versuchen so viel wie möglich während
des spielens zu erzählen und eben durch
das gameplay sachen zu erzählen und da
gibt es doch gar keine konventionen
nicht es gibt
kaum was darüber zu lesen es ist halt
alles neuland
also treu obwohl es die gaming branche
schon seit den 70er jahren gibt ist
steht sie noch ganz am anfang
ja und ich hoffe das wird noch ein
augenblick lang so bleiben weil der
forschergeist treibt uns natürlich auch
alle aber es ist eben nicht nur in den
erzählerischen computerspielen so sagen
ich glaube das gilt für alle bereiche
und ja ich hoffe dass wir nicht wieder
so eine faser leben in dem ich spiele
sich alt quasi so in ihrem genre fest
faden und das dann halt einfach nur neue
varianten desselben spiel zum prinzip
entstehen sondern dass es so bleibt wie
es jetzt gerade ist das halt in viele
impulse zusammenkommen und sich das
ganze halt irgendwie sehr rasant
weiterentwickelt auch auf neue
plattformen und eben auch für neue
zielgruppen ok meine ganze menge in der
entwicklung auch eine frage zum schluss
ganz anders wenn jemand wie krank so ein
spiel wie edna bricht aus spielt oder
habe ich neue augen was für folgen hat
das
es ist halt ganz also das hat schon eine
kleine explosion bei uns verursacht er
plötzlich ganz ganz neue fans habt also
vorher haben unsere spiele glaube ich
oder nach unserer erfahrung nach dem was
wir wissen wo vorher unsere spiele
hauptsächlich leute wie wir gespielt
also leute alte leute mit burton die
alte den achtzigern die spiele gerne
gespielt haben und uns war schon klar
deshalb die jungen spieler die kommende
generation also die die neuen spieler
die heutigen spieler dass die halt
mitunter gar nicht mehr wissen was
überhaupt ein point click adventure ist
und was es damals für uns bedeutet hat
das waren die allerersten spiele weil
was anderes ging gar nicht ja in den
späten siebzigern für die mal zu hause
spielen genau unter das freut mich
natürlich dass wir halt irgendwie dazu
beitragen können dass wir dieses spiel
erlebnis einer neuen generation eben mit
nach unserem zusätzlichen gewürzen
zugänglich zu machen ok super bubi
vielen dank ja ich danke danke ich auch
wenn euch der tor gefallen hat mit profi
dann dürft euch auch der mittlere floyd
gefallen wo darum geht ob er vergleicht
für die lsd
programm ist
vater in form und lustig und spannend
auf der metallbox dennis schneider der
sl champion
der über gefahr
4 das gaming gut
wobei
das dp zb